good morning John so last week I went to
YouTube like YouTube headquarters the
physical space that YouTube occupies
where all the people who make the site
work up under people were there to talk
about educating through online video
which is obvious listen that's really
important to me and I'm really
interested in I would show you that he
loved it but it turns out that you
cannot make videos inside of YouTube
which is like a really great explanation
of what the technical definition of
irony is it was really fantastic really
inspiring really great to talk to
teachers about how they use our content
in our classroom I also got this totally
swag headband so there's bad but it is
sometimes a little bit easy to lose
track of what the point of it all is
which is why I'm glad that youtube ended
the event by taking everybody to the
Exploratorium in San Francisco which is
like the original Science Center it's so
cool dorium is built for young people
for students to interact with and to
learn and to teach themselves and to get
excited about learning but it was
amazing to go through this place with
vihart and Derek from veritasium and
Destin from smarter every day
CGP grey and Henry from minutephysics
because while they are not children they
are mature adults that are extremely
intelligent smartest people I've ever
met they are everybody is curious about
the world as the most curious second
grader in this place right education is
about learning and about teaching and
about knowing but I think the most
important piece of it is inspiring
curiosity and understanding how
important curiosity is and I've been
thinking about this and I think the
curiosity may be the finest human
quality you can make the argument for
love but love also is is limited it only
reaches so far and it comes along with
like control and envy and you know a lot
of hatred is born in love curiosity in
some ways is like the opposite of
judgment you can't hate something if
you're curious about it and really you
can be curious about everything
curiosity can lead to the creation of
some terrible things I will admit that I
think only is a side affair to know and
understand and seeing the world as a
puzzle that's begging to be solved it's
just really lovely it's one of my very
favorite hobbies
I like to take that information and then
scrunch it up into interesting shapes
and then share it back out with the
world if I can share that feeling and
put it out there to the world and have
more people who are curious more people
who see the world of that kind of puzzle
or do you know who want to know for
knowings sake I think that that's our
really good path for the world to be
walking down to be a better place in the
future very happy very lucky to be a
part of that so thanks to all the people
who made that event so great and I'm
sorry that you could be there but I
guess that filming a movie in Amsterdam
is a pretty good excuse
I loved your video this week really
important I think for for us just you
and me as brothers but also for this
whole community I love explaining things
but I also love doing things that could
never have been done before because this
is such an interesting community I think
if you really feel like it's unique in
the history of the world and so that's
cool right being able to come together
and use this interest to do cool things
that's the most interesting opportunity
that we have there are for example lots
of genius and terrifying punishment
suggestions we're gonna get them
together then we're gonna have a poll it
also occurs to me that it is October and
it is pumpkin-carving season so we're
gonna have a contest nerdfighter pumpkin
carvings there's a post on our pants
there's a link to it in the description
post your nerdfighter pumpkin carvings
in there the top ten by number of up
votes they get on the forum will receive
a look from my bookshelf that I think
you should read inscribed from me to you
and we will also of course feature the
pumpkins in a video John thank you for
being awesome and I will see you on
Tuesday